[Music]
we're eternals
seven thousand years we've protected
humans from the demons
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere
until now
you hear that eternal's assembled
hi
hello hey who's your gardener
this planet and these people have
changed all of us
when you love something
you protect it
for eternity
[Music]
marvel studios eternals what's your
superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked
pg-13 get tickets now
why didn't you guys help fight thanos
or any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless stevens are
involved
[Music]
the turtles explore the very creation of
the marvel universe itself
the film also deals very much with the
aftermath of avengers 4 and the state
the world is in five of the eternals are
more of the thinkers
and the other five are the stronger
fighters
the eternals are these remarkably
superpowered characters
but also a dysfunctional family unit
this is what the end of the world looks
like at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm the person to bring that
together was academy award winner
claudia
we go on these emotional journeys with
these eternals
to figure out who they are and what it
means to be human
her vision
is so clear
it's not the typical place it's not the
typical shots it's not the typical cast
everybody looks different everybody
sounds different
a lot of people are going to see
themselves as superheroes for the first
time
really is an epic global film the scope
and the scale of it is huge
it's so exciting to be part of something
that really feels new
the impact that eternals will have on
the mcu will be nothing less than
redefining the cinematic universe
entirely
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
you